- I'm excited, I'm so excited.
Ready to go, let's do it!
Next up we're going to.
Where are we going?
- I don't know.
- Star Wars launch bay.
- Oh no.
- Oh wow.
Good morning Believe Nation.
Where are we off to guys?
- [Kids] Hollywood Studios.
- I don't know about
the energy level guys.
I feel like we can come up a little bit
but we'll save it for later.
It is day six.
We're up early today, earlier than normal
because we need to get in
line for the jedi training.
This thing has limited seating
and all the kids run to.
So we got to get there
to make sure that we have time to do it.
I had a dream last night
that I was accidentally hosting
two events at the same time.
It was very stressful.
I was stressed out trying to
make it happen for everybody
and be happy.
But I woke up and I have the non stress
of planning our Disney vacation.
So that's the good news.
And getting all these
guys ready in the morning.
Right?
- Yeah.
- That's not stressful right, it's easy.
It's just tell the kids to do it once
and then it gets done.
Here we go, Hollywood Studios!
- [Kid] Whoo hoo!
(bright music)
- Look at that morning sunrise.
Disney's Hollywood Studios.
Very exciting.
Alright, we made it.
There's almost nobody
here, it's very exciting.
We're going to get our jedi training spot.
If we didn't get jedi training
the kids would be very upset
and freaking out, so.
Plan is, get to the entrance,
see when they let us in.
Nina and the kids go to
jedi training to line up.
Husband goes and gets some coffee.
'Cause Nina wants coffee.
- Yes.
- You do?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Maybe today no coffee?
- Then we'll go home to sleep.
- Oh wow, 'kay.
Well then we're going to
get some coffee for Nina.
'Cause we love her.
You guys ready?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
Alright, let's go.
(bright music)
- Alright we made it, we're
one of the first people.
And then we have to spend an hour in line
waiting for the gates to open.
I need my coffee.
But we'll be the first
ones in the jedi training,
and to Starbucks, minimize the lines.
I'm in, I'm in, let's go.
The kids are running to jedi.
Look at the line up for Starbucks.
It's already longer than any line up here.
Look at this.
Holy cow.
The things we do for love, right?
Nina's got to be happy.
She'll be happier with the coffee.
She does a lot, she's done a lot.
She's done a lot this whole trip
to keep everybody organized
and on track, happy.
So we got to do the good thing for her.
(bright music)
Nina has her coffee.
Drink up.
Yummy.
- We're going to jedi training,
we're going to jedi training.
- [Evan] Get to meet Olaf.
Was that good?
- [Boy] Yes.
- Did you have fun?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Good idea?
- Yes.
- Alright.
Jedi training time.
You ready Hayden?
(dramatic music)
We're going.
Are you excited?
What are you going to do?
- Fight the dark side.
(Evan laughs)
- [Evan] You liked it?
Did you have fun?
- Yeah, I fought the last time.
- [Nina] Here, careful.
(Hayden mumbles)
- [Evan] What did you say?
- I fought the seven
sisters, the 2nd time.
- [Evan] Let's see your ready position.
Ho, let's do it.
Cut to the head, do the whole thing.
- No.
- No?
Alright.
(bright music)
Nina's getting her steps in.
Standing in line.
And stepping.
Here we go.
What do you think of this one?
- Good.
- They changed it.
- Yeah.
They did.
- [Evan] Was it better or worse?
- I liked it.
- Good?
Alright.
Next up we're going
to, where are we going?
- I don't know.
- Star Wars launch bay.
- Oh no.
- Oh wow.
That's the excitement.
That's the excitement friends.
That is the excitement.
Jeffrey, next stop, Star Wars launch bay!
- Hooray!
- Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
Alright, are we ready for lunch?
- Yeah!
- Ready for lunch.
We're going to have some
gourmet inspired hot dogs
in a new place.
Let's see how good they are.
Gourmet hot dogs.
Let's tell Nina.
Nina, time for some gourmet hot dogs.
- What?
- Gourmet hot dogs.
- Oh really?
- New place, just opened up.
- Did it?
- Yep.
Nina looks very excited by this.
She's very excited.
Alright, time to eat.
We got our guac and our sour cream
and our humongous hot dogs.
And nachos for everybody.
Have a bite guys.
- What are these?
- Cookies.
- Those are mine.
- Oh this is good, oh this is good.
Good stuff.
Thanks a lot Daddy.
- Alright, enjoy guys.
(bright music)
It finally warmed up
enough to wear t-shirts.
Whoo t-shirt weather.
Alright, we're going to
watch a Star Wars show now.
(dramatic music)
You like that?
- Yep.
- [Evan] Yeah, alright.
- [Jeffrey] See that much.
- Alright, it's muppet time.
(bright music)
I like this one.
- Now where are we going?
- [Evan] Did Nina fall asleep?
- A little bit.
- Now where are we going?
Now where are we going?
- [Evan] Was that fun?
- Yep.
- Yeah.
Now where are we going?
- Somewhere.
It's time to use our first fast pass.
- On, Star Tours?
- On Star Tours!
- [Hayden] Whoo!
Nice dress Hayden.
- Alright, well Hayden's excited.
(Evan laughing)
- I'm excited.
- Alright, let's go.
Let's go through in the inside.
(upbeat music)
Show time.
How was it?
- Good.
- Very good.
- [Evan] Very good?
- [Hayden] Yeah.
- [Evan] Yeah?
- I liked the.
- It was fun.
- [Evan] So much fun?
- It was a blast.
- How 'about you Nina?
- Very good.
- I feel a little nauseous.
Feel a little nauseous.
Oh you feel nauseous?
- Yeah.
- Why didn't you say that?
It was good.
I couldn't nap.
That's Nina's criteria for
a good is if she can nap.
I feel a little nauseous.
Yeah, they changed it up again.
It wasn't the same one as last year.
Anyway.
Okay, the day continues.
(bright music)
Now we're going to go
watch the Star Wars movie.
- Is it actually a movie?
- The new one.
Here we go.
Nina totally passed out.
She had her head on my shoulder.
And I had to use my head to prop her up
'cause she kept falling down.
I didn't want to wake her up.
- Luke and Leah are sisters.
- Luke and Leah are sisters?
- Yeah.
- Next up, Frozen, Let it Go.
- No.
- Let's tell Stephanie.
Next up, Frozen, Let it Go.
- Yay.
(laughing)
- Teamwork?
(bright music)
- There are more movies
coming out of Star Wars.
(mumbles)
- [Evan] How do you know?
- Because.
- [Evan] You just know?
- I know everything.
- You know everything?
- Carmichael.
- 'Cause you're Hayden Carmichael?
- I see all and know all.
- I don't mind that.
(happy music)
♫ I don't care what they're going say
♫ Let the storm rage on
♫ The cold never bothered me any way
How was it?
- It was good.
(mumbles)
- Nina's saying a lie.
How was it?
- Good, good.
- Good.
Okay, next up.
Indiana Jones, Indiana Jones!
- Whoo hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
(dramatic music)
- What did you think mister?
- Good.
- [Evan] Yeah?
What was your favorite part?
- When everything blew up.
- Nice, how did it look?
Do a demonstration.
Nice.
Where are the boys?
Is this Hayden?
So, we just finished Indiana Jones.
You know what we're doing next?
- What?
- No.
Maybe some ice cream.
- [Boys] Yay.
- [Evan] What do we think guys?
How's the ice cream?
- Amazing.
- [Evan] Amazing, yummy?
Umm.
There's one thing left.
You know what it is?
- What?
- [Evan] Toy Story ride!
- Yay.
(bright music)
- [Evan] Someone's enjoying
his vanilla ice cream.
And stoning out at the same time.
Hello.
- I'm not.
- [Evan] No?
Yummy.
If you can't finish it, I can eat it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Nina caught something on Pokemon.
- Hayden, I can't see with you hat.
- What did you catch?
- A cow, she caught a cow.
- It's a dog calf.
- Whoa, can I got after Pokemon.
Hurry up.
- Oh, hold on I can't see.
- It's a houndour.
- [Nina] What's a hounder?
Okay, whatever.
- These guys are obsessed with Pokemon Go,
'cause you can catch different Pokemons
compared to what we get in Toronto.
Nina's leading the
charge in this insanity,
but I support it, 'cause we love Nina.
And we love the kids.
It's about them having fun.
So this is them having fun.
Did you get it?
- Yes.
- Good high five.
Good job.
Hayden.
You know.
Make the family happy.
Here it comes.
Here it is, high five that up.
Boom.
(bright music)
Final stop is the Toy Story ride.
Where we go with our 3D glasses
and fight off the enemy.
I won't be able to film inside,
but again, I'm looking
forward to defending my score
on our last ride at Disney World.
Who's excited?
- Me!
(upbeat music)
- Last ride.
- [Evan] Last ride.
- I'm a jedi.
- [Evan] Hello jedi Hayden.
You excited?
Nice.
Jeffrey's excited.
- Yes!
My favorite ride.
- Whoo!
- [Evan] He's excited.
- I'm ready.
Last ride, oh wow, she's really ready.
Nina means business.
- Game face.
Let's see your game face.
Bless you Nina.
Believe Nation, give Nina
a bless you Nina in the comments.
Bless you Nina in the comments.
I'm excited.
I'm so excited.
Ready to go, let's do it!
We're on next.
- Oh Hayden, Jeffrey.
- Hayden, Jeffrey.
Hayden, Stephanie!
Whoo!
Alright, my final score is...
186,500.
Yeah!
Nice.
Pretty sure I took that one.
Very exciting.
Best in the vehicle.
Best this hour, holy cow,
somebody got 462, that's crazy.
- How many points did you get?
- [Evan] A lot.
- Tell me the exact number.
- [Evan] I got a lot.
- Tell me please.
Please?
- [Evan] Did you guys have fun?
- [Kid] Yes.
- Yeah.
Now tell me what you got.
- [Evan] What'd you get?
- I got 131,400, no 900.
- I got one million. (laughing)
- [Evan] 130?
- 130, almost 132,000.
- [Evan] Did you beat Jeffrey?
- Jeffrey has 80, almost 82,000.
- Yeah.
- And Hayden?
- I got (mumbles).
- I got 67,900.
- [Evan] Good job guys.
- What'd you get?
- 185.
- What, 185?
- Thousand.
Good times.
(laughing)
Listen, it's not about winning,
it's about playing right.
And it's about winning.
It's really about winning.
Playing fair, but winning.
Okay.
We're going, did you have fun?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So thank you guys for joining us
for day?
- Six.
- Six?
Day six.
Tomorrow we are off to Universal Studios.
Hope you enjoyed this video,
like we enjoyed today.
You continue to
- [All] Believe.
- And we'll see you soon.
- And whatever you want, what is.
- Oh nice, good job Nina, good job.
High five for that.
(laughing)